make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and we are picking back
up again with the conclusion of the
great society this
marks the ending of the quote-unquote
incursion story arc from jonathan
hickman right so those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with this uh
technically it's broken down by volumes
in the sense that you do have like the
trade paperbacks in terms of how they're
read
the best way to do it is to go issue by
issue right because what you end up
having is like one issue where something
happens you have like an issue of new
avengers then you go into like three or
four issues of avengers then you go into
like three issues of new avengers then
one issue of avengers when you get the
trades you're just getting them in bulk
so you're getting like the first six
issues of avengers
the next six issues of avengers it's
better when it's read issue by issue but
what you have are like great big huge
sections right great big huge arcs and
this one the the incursions are expand
something like like 22 or 23 different
comics right it's pretty lengthy and
that's really what we've been covering
here for a little while but the idea is
that with
the last video we did we talked about
how the great society was basically dc's
justice league from an alternate reality
but what we end up doing is picking up
with doctor strange
basically at the the resolute throne
right the intention of selling his soul
for absolute power in this instance we
kind of have to dive into a little bit
of hearsay and haphazard guessing and
the reason why is because we're not
really given definitive explanations
here by jonathan hickman when we say
things or we hear things like
absolute power right all everything the
godhead when we hear that what we're
kind of left to believe here
is that it would essentially be doctor
strange becoming the one above all right
having absolute power
enough to wipe out or destroy entire
worlds and and it kind of
points to the idea that stephen strange
would be more powerful than he was when
he originally popped up in marvel comics
that he was a guy who could basically do
anything
because a spell existed for it and
marvel comics writers could just make up
spells to explain why steven strange
could do stuff
the other part of this is we're talking
about stephen strange going back to the
way he was as powerful before but he
wasn't as powerful as a living tribunal
when he first popped up or even the one
above all he was capable
with regards to a few things but when
you put them pound for pound steven
strange was not powerful enough to like
wipe out entire universes
or anything along those lines so we're
kind of left to sort of guess here
the other part of this is that
ultimately uh steven strange is denied
absolute power and the reason why is
because again he's bargaining his soul
for 100 power which means he has to be
willing to give away 100
of his soul the problem with this is he
doesn't have 100 of his soul
now again this is where we have to sort
of delve into this guesswork jonathan
hickman doesn't give us a definitive
explanation as to why this is the case
we're kind of left to sort of look at
the nature of steven strange
and come to a decision on our own the
fortunate thing about this is that over
the years of marvel comics we've kind of
gotten these explanations to a degree
we have seen things where you had like
the the mystical war between the
vashanti
and ultimately doctor strange chose not
to take their side which is where his
power was reduced when they stripped him
of his ability to use their magics uh
ultimately he ended up going back to
himself but only with a with a fraction
of the power he had before
it was a way for marvel to basically
just reduce his abilities so he wasn't a
guy who could just solve any problem by
doing weird looking hand gestures and
then the day was safe it was designed to
kind of prevent that stuff from
happening
uh but over the years steven strange has
delved into black magic
and on the whole stephen strange doesn't
normally do that because the
conversation is always that when you
delve into that kind of magic there's a
price to be paid and the implication
seems to be that stephen strange
lost a piece of his soul every time that
he did that's the price that you pay you
lose a piece of yourself and so over the
years with steven strange delving into
these dark magics he's cost himself a
portion of his soul each time hence the
reason why he does not have 100 of his
soul and so as a result of that what we
end up doing is jumping
back to the here and now and we pick up
with this battle between the great
society and the illuminati themselves
and you've got like the norn who again
is basically dr fate from dc comics and
initially he scans the landscape trying
to hunt for this bomb and realizes that
it's not actually on this alternate
reality earth that it's on the earth
where the illuminati come from the main
marvel universe earth and it makes the
most sense right if you were gonna have
like a fail-safe device like a
just-in-case backup plan why would you
bring it with you if you could just
detonate it remotely or just like
teleport it there right something like
that it'd be a stupid decision to make
so what ends up happening is that with
the norn figuring out where this is he
dispatches spectrum which is again
marvel's version of the green lantern
basically dc's green lantern uh he
dispatches spectrum to go basically
track it down
and black bolt follow spectrum from
there you get a little bit of trash talk
with neymar the submariner facing off
against the jovian and the jovian again
is basically martian manhunter
and and namor kind of kind of you know
pokes them a little bit and says like
you know it sucks that it kind of has to
come to this but it's just the way that
it is
you know you fight new claw and you're
and you're desperate to survive but the
one thing you fail to understand
is that in the end there's really
nothing you can do and this kind of
hopelessness that name of the submariner
has to a degree which will become
stupendously important as we get further
into the story is countered by the
hopeful nature of the jovian and saying
it sucks that you view yourself this way
it sucks that you see yourself in such a
way
to where you don't really believe that
the day can be saved that you really are
that hopeless
but allow me to correct you right and
the jovian in turn takes on its physical
form or really takes on more of like a
shape-shifting form
right from there you switch over to
wayne who's basically batman and he's
facing off against black panther now
something that hickman does here which
is really interesting is hickman has
black panther make this off-handed
comment
that basically he's a great fighter
right that wayne is a great fighter and
may very well be better than black
panther the reason why
that matters is one of the most hotly
debated topics in all of
comicdom is who would win in a fight
black panther or batman now my vote goes
to black panther for a few reasons one
because of the enhanced abilities he has
by virtue of the panther god bast
the next one is because of the various
technologies he has right to the
vibranium
suit which basically absorbs sound the
adamantium claws that he has as a part
of his suit the most
durable metal like the hardest metal in
all of marvel comics the only exception
being
thor's hammer which adamantium cannot
cut and captain america's shield
as well like you know having these kind
of things at his disposal i think would
put black panther on top of
of batman but it's one of the reasons
why you kind of see this right it's
almost kind of like hey like maybe you
are a better fighter than i am you know
like here you go batman fans we're not
going to say it directly as marvel
comics because you know like we're
marvel comics and black panthers of
marvel property
but if we were going pound for pound
batman will probably come out on top
that's kind of what hickman's saying
here right so i feel like it's sort of a
one-up for batman fans to be like yeah
that's pretty much right
you know batman would win for no other
reason than the fact that he's batman
and that's all you need
but then you got sun god who takes on
the incredible hulk and manages to take
the incredible hulk out what you're
basically seeing here is that each one
of the members of the illuminati are
falling before the power of the great
society you're talking about some
wildly powerful individuals and so when
it all comes down to it all you really
have left is iron man
and doctor strange who's recovering and
then iron man of course has his powers
taken out by basically you know
you know marvel's version of the flash
who can move faster than the speed of
light and it's kind of funny because she
makes this offhand to remark for all
your intelligence
it's useless here because i can move
faster than you can think so your
intelligence is useless by the time the
thought goes from your subconscious mind
into your conscious mind that you should
do something i've already done
everything that i'm going to do which is
taking apart your suit you're useless
old man you got nothing to offer here
and he doesn't right tony stark is
dismantled entirely
enter dr strange and this is probably
one of the best moments of all of doctor
strange
the truth is that the norn gets a little
big for his britches right he's kind of
one of these things where it's like you
know i have all this magical ability
like you should it should be obvious
with all these foes and all these these
you know with with my group with the
great society you facing off against us
you can't win and it was foolish for you
to come here and to believe that you
could somehow destroy us
and then wipe our world out and doctor
strange responds
by just starting to utter an incantation
and what this does is it basically
transitions
back to uh to before this whole
incursion took place and doctor strange
focusing on the blood of core now the
bloody core
is is an artifact that was introduced in
this story but given the nature of
doctor strange we can pretty much sort
of get it right that with stephen
strange what you have are basically
different magical books that will grant
him different magical abilities
some spells will let him time travel
other spells will let him jump from one
universe to another other spells will
grant him reality warping powers it
depends on what it is that he wants to
do
but some spells that are out there come
from dark books and the blood of core is
an example of that this is a book that's
composed of exceedingly dark spells of
evil and and just
terrible things and what doctor strange
is doing is basically summoning this
demonic entity from the blood of court
itself
this basically means that stephen
strange is at a point of desperation
because
if he didn't have to do this he wouldn't
but ultimately there's really nothing
they can do
the other part of this is he confronts
the norn and says i need to understand
something right like what i've noticed
about you
is you don't have any magical abilities
you look like you do
but you don't right you don't know the
dark arts you don't know what it costs
you to be a magician to be a
practitioner of magic to delve and to
pull in these various forces from across
the multiverse each of which would take
a piece of your soul every time that you
do
you're a charlatan you're a person who's
captured these different artifacts from
these
different beings that you guys have
encountered whether it's you know native
villains on your own planet or the black
priest when they showed up from an
alternate reality but you're you're fake
there's nothing about you that's real
and so ultimately he ends up casting
aside all these different artifacts that
the norn has
and it's just some kid right it's just
some young kid pretending to be somebody
like stephen strange and steven responds
let me show you what the dark arts
really look like let me show you what
happens when you're a person who can
truly conjure
demonic beasts and let me show you what
they look like and this is when this
demon
starts to emerge and his tentacles come
out and start wrapping around
everybody and just draining them all of
their life force right draining every
single one of them of all of their life
energies the problem with this is that
the longer stephen strange allows this
demon to exist
on this plane of existence the more
stephen strange becomes corrupted by it
and that's the danger of summoning
beings
like this now the other question we kind
of have to ask here is why this guy
right why not summon someone like shuma
gorath or something like that or channel
the power of zom right we know zom
is a being that's wildly powerful if zom
showed up in the main marvel universe
right now
nobody outside of like the living
tribunal would be able to stop him right
just the living tribunal or like the one
above all
if they didn't step in zom would wipe
out everything across the entirety of
the universe right dormammu
all these different characters eternity
infinity they would all be obliterated
by the power of zom that's just how
powerful he
is the reason why we kind of have to
assume that is because one there's no
guarantee that zom would even lend his
power to steven strange in the first
place and as far as schuma gorath goes
if doctor strange unleashed him onto the
great society the first thing shu
mcgrath would try to do is basically
take over the illuminati subjugate them
turn them into his servants do the same
thing with the great society and then
conquer that world so it's not like
steven strange would be able to summon
schumacherath in the days saved they'd
have a massive threat to deal with on
their own and so that's why this
particular monster was was brought in
here right because it's powerful enough
to overcome the great society but not so
dangerous that none of the illuminati
can overcome him if that's the case and
steven strange is kind of betting on the
illuminati themselves right because as
he continues to allow this demon to
exist he begins to become corrupted by
its influence and begins to go mad right
he begins to go insane through this
possession that he's experiencing this
leads to tony stark basically knocking
him out using a you know
a part of his uh energy pulses basically
and of course back on the in the main
marvel universe uh you have black ball
who catches up with spectrum he uses
this quasi-sonic scream basically like
his powerful shout to knockout spectrum
and then takes the bomb and brings
it back to uh to the great society's
earth and so with steven strange knocked
out and with the bomb back here then the
conversation turns to
okay now it's time to consider
destroying this world and what you end
up having and it's probably one of the
saddest moments here is sun god like
approaches the heroes and says like it
doesn't have to be this way like you
don't have to destroy my world you don't
have to kill
all these innocent people here these
billions and billions of humans who
don't even know that this conflict is
going on in the first place you don't
need to do any of this
and the response of reed richards and
the illuminati is if we could get away
without destroying your world we would
but we're this close we're hours away
from this incursion
completing from your earth hitting our
earth and both of our realities being
destroyed so uh
i don't know what to tell you man like
one of these earth has to go and it's
not
to be ours right it's a tough decision
to make and black panther almost you
know kind of takes this this trigger
unto himself and says i'll be the one to
do it and this is one of the coolest
moments in the entirety of the story
because when this happens
black panther is met by his ancestors
right who basically say
you know what you have to do but
t'challa is experiencing this massive
inner turmoil because it's one thing to
say i'm a king and i'm going to protect
my my kingdom of wakanda from whatever
threats may come
but more often than not when you make
that statement you assume the threats
are malicious
you assume it's somebody like ulysses
claw who's trying to break into wakanda
and steal his technology you assume that
it's some external force out there like
doctor doom that's trying to do what he
did in doom war which is set up a coup
d'etat and steal all the vibranium in
wakanda which he successfully did like
you assume that it's some nefarious plot
or something you don't really think
about it from the perspective of
a world inhabited by billions of people
through no fault of their own instead of
sitting on a collision course towards
yours and if both your ears crash into
each other
both realities get destroyed and that's
what t'challa is weighing here
is it's not some evil threat these are
innocent people they don't have control
over this situation but i'm sitting here
plotting the concept of destroying the
world anyway
in order to save our own his ancestors
do not have this kind of struggle
their response is destroy the world it's
a threat to wakanda and that's the
difference between t'challa and a lot of
his ancestors right his ancestors were
hardcore
anything out there this incredible
threat to wakanda has to go
it's got to be taken care of it's got to
be neutralized by hooker by crook
it doesn't matter but for t'challa it's
a little more nuanced than that and
ultimately he ends up basically telling
his father's spiritual form
i can't do it but i can't pull this
trigger and i can't destroy all these
people in return
his father banishes him from the
afterlife what this basically means is
that when t'challa dies he will not join
his ancestors he will not be among those
former black panthers because
as far as they're concerned they see him
as a traitor somebody who stood against
wakanda in a time when wakanda needed to
be safe right
the role of a king is to protect his
people by any means necessary it doesn't
matter where that threat comes from and
it doesn't matter who that threat is
if it's a threat it gets destroyed no
questions asked but the fact that
t'challa can't really do it is an
indication to his ancestors he's no true
king he's no true black panther he's a
half measure and so ultimately
he's banished from from the eternal
plane of all the black panthers and so
whatever black panthers come after him
when they go to speak with their
ancestors t'challa will not be there he
will not be a black panther they can
commune with that's a pretty
significant thing in response to that
name with a submariner picks up the
trigger and basically says like i'm the
greatest man that i know you know
compared to me
you guys are nothing you guys are
absolutely nothing the reality of this
is we knew it would come to this and so
if you can't do it
i will and name of the submariner
activates the trigger and blows the
planet to pieces right destroys that
entire
earth and kills billions of people along
with it in response to this
he goes on like this sort of amazing
this amazing monologue where he says
like it's such a fragile thing right
this trigger
six pounds of pressure is all it took to
to send an electrical signal to a bomb
on a different world and wipe out the
whole thing and i find myself
asking how could that be done and then i
find myself answering that's right
it was built for that purpose we built
these bombs if we didn't think it would
come to this
why did we build them we built them
because we knew it would we built them
because we knew a time would come
when we were going to have to detonate a
bomb on one of these worlds and wipe out
innocent people
we accepted that fact we are fallen men
right we are men who are willing to wipe
out
entire civilizations in order to
preserve our own universe that's the way
this goes you guys
knew what you were signing up for and
now when it comes down to it when you've
gotta actually do it
suddenly you turn into cowards suddenly
you turn into weaklings weak-willed men
who can't do what needs to be done black
panther freaks
immediately goes on a warp path and
starts attacking the name of the
submariner reed richards
jumps in right basically kind of wraps
himself around begins to sort of break
the two of them up and then tony stark
chimes in and says
we didn't believe it would actually come
to this yes we built those but those
were just a just
in case we believed that when the time
came that we'd be able to find some kind
of scenario where we could save both
worlds the response of namor you're a
fool tony stark if you really believe
that if you really believe that with
these incursions happening the way that
they were
that every earth that we went to would
have people who would want to have some
kind of peaceful negotiation who would
want to talk to us
and to ensure that we didn't destroy our
world and they didn't destroy theirs
you're an idiot because you have to
understand
people out there on their worlds want to
save those worlds and what if we
encounter other realities where the
people there are evil well they want to
destroy our world and they wouldn't
think two things about it are you still
to talk to him are you still going to
try to have a conversation with him no
the people who save the day the people
who win wars are ones who do what needs
to be done
not those individuals who just want to
talk and have a conversation
they're half measures they're weak
willed men be a grown man
be a strong man or get out of here be no
man at all and so with that being the
case again the fight is kind of on to a
degree between black panther and
name with a submariner and then the
incredible hulk steps in smashes the
ground and splits the two of them up and
where there is a bit of a reprieve here
right where there is a little bit of a
moment
where it seems like everything has kind
of died down the response of neymar he
basically tells black panther
it was me and black panther thinks he's
talking about the trigger right he
thinks he's talking about the the bomb
that was detonated and black panther's
like yeah we know it was and he says no
it was me
right now if you guys recall our video
where we talked about how doctor strange
ended up summoning schuma goras during
the events of infinity when thanos
invaded earth
we talked about how uh the the forces of
proxima midnight and with supergiant
black dwarf all those different guys the
the call obsidian
how they had traveled to atlantis and
then inexplicably left atlantis and then
went to wakanda the reason why is
because
neymar told them to but what ended up
happening is that in the aftermath
of the avengers versus x-men story arc
right so name of the submariner becomes
part of the phoenix force and then he
obliterates a huge portion of wakanda
that wakanda was still recovering but
where t'challa was no longer the black
panther and instead it was his sister
shuri
she decided to go to war with atlantis
and so with that being the case uh
wakandan black ops forces infiltrated
atlantis while namor was away during
these incursions and then
wiped out a huge portion of his people
when namor finally got back there he
found his own kingdom completely
decimated and so when the black order of
thanos showed up on earth looking for
the infinity stones and they showed up
in atlantis
namor said there are no infinity stones
here but i do know where you can find
them you can find them in wakanda right
he knew they weren't there he knew there
were no infinity stones there what he
wanted to do was see what was left of
wakanda
laid waste by the black order of thanos
which he knew they would most likely do
and that's exactly what they did they
showed up to wakanda all hell broke
loose now
now fortunately wakana managed to fight
a lot of them off but not without a
whole bunch of deaths at the hands of of
the black order and so with with
t'challa realizing this that namor
intentionally sent the forces of thanos
to wakanda for no other reason than to
basically get revenge and to see the
death of his people and with name one of
the submariners saying i don't regret it
and if given the opportunity i would
watch your people die again
black panther is incensed and absolutely
freaks i mean this guy is seeing red
because the reality of this is that
where black panther where t'challa
wasn't really in a position and didn't
really want to destroy a world of
innocent people
understand it doesn't mean he doesn't
care about his people doesn't mean he
doesn't care about wakanda he'll do
whatever he needs to do to protect them
with the exception of killing billions
of innocents right
people who would basically be collateral
damage and no conflict of their own
fault and so with this being the case he
loses his mind right absolutely
freaks out and tries to destroy neymar
now namor is sent away by tony stark
right he's told get out of here
like get out of here and do not come
back and so where you have the other
members of the illuminati who begin
going their separate ways right who
begin basically leaving
suddenly reed richard's hand lights up
because another incursion is happening
in seven hours and 55 minutes they keep
coming
faster they keep coming sooner right
it's just the way this goes and so what
you end up having here
is basically a countdown to the
incursion time right we pick up you know
seven
hours before the incursion happens
you've got bruce banner who's basically
just kind of sitting there enjoying a
beer and almost with his incredible hulk
persona and for the first time in a long
time
bruce banner is actually at peace
knowing everything is going to end he's
at peace right he chills here for a few
hours so at this point we're at three
hours until the incursion point happens
you end up picking up with doctor
strange who's talking to wong and it's
one of the coolest conversations because
when he's talking to his assistant wong
he starts asking questions saying things
like you know i i don't know who i am
anymore you know i delved into the
bloody core i
i tried to sell 100 of my soul for 100
percent of absolute power i've done
dark things in my life i've done it for
the purpose of trying to save our
universe our reality from threats like
dormammu
and nightmare and like an instantaneous
and like schumacher
i've done it over and over and over
again but i don't know
if this makes me a good man and he asks
one with all the evil that i've done
in the name of good am i a good person
and the response of wong
is no you're not you are not a good
person like you're basically a bad guy
now
but you're willing to sacrifice the end
of the lives of innocent people even if
they are in a different reality for the
purpose of saving your own from there
you transition to tony stark one hour
until the incursion happens until
both these worlds collide into each
other or until this earth is destroyed
whatever the case is but until like
this reality is totally obliterated
right so it's basically one hour until
the end of this universe
you've got tony stark who lines up a
whole bunch of shots and the initial
thought is
he's relapsing right he's going back
into alcoholism he's not what he's doing
is he's pouring all these different
shots and says okay i couldn't save my
universe right we've got one hour until
the incursion we've got no plan we're
not mobilized you know
destroying that world like that really
showed us what it is we would have to do
and we're just not willing to do it i'm
i'm done right like you know i'm not
you know if there's any one thing in
this universe that i can beat it's
alcohol right i am not going to succumb
to my alcoholism
even in my last days that's not going to
happen and so what you do
is you pick up with reed richards
alongside susan storm now one thing to
understand
susan storm doesn't know what's going on
right you know the wife of reed richards
and the fantastic four the invisible
woman she has no idea what's happening
here she doesn't know about the
incursion she doesn't know about the
collapse of the multiverse she doesn't
know that their reality is something
like 45 minutes away from coming to an
end from being totally obliterated right
reed richards on the other hand has has
been acting in a way
that looks frantic to susan storm right
he looks manic he's been traveling to go
see franklin richards he wanted to spend
time with his son to have a conversation
with him to have a heart-to-heart
to assure him that everything was going
to be okay with no real explanation that
was given he's gone here to castle doom
to latviria right where doctor doom
dwells and basically wants to meet with
his daughter valeria who's staying with
victor von doom for a time and and a lot
of it just kind of seems wild and it
seems off the charts it's things that
reed richards wouldn't normally do and
you've got doctor doom talking to susan
and asking the question
do you know why reed is here like do you
know why he came here in the middle of
the night in order to talk to valeria
and the response to susan is
no but i trust my husband implicitly but
again when he asks like he gave you no
answer whatsoever
she says no i don't know you know i have
no i really honestly have no clue why
we're here or what's going on and doctor
doom asks does that concern you as much
as it concerns me
and she says yes because this is very
uncharacteristic of reed richards but
valeria
is no slouch remember she's one of the
three smartest people in the marvel
universe you've got valeria richards
reed richards and you've got uh you got
doctor doom right valeria you know
this kind of top three spot or this
number one spot switches among these
three different characters
depending on who's writing the story but
more often than not these three are
depicted as the smartest people in the
entirety of the marvel universe valeria
takes one look at her dad
and says what have you done we're five
minutes from the incursion happening
we're five minutes from the end of all
things you've got black bolt of the
inhumans who's just sitting on the on
the oxygen-rich blue area of the moon
just staring at earth
knowing that it's all getting ready to
come to an end and kind of lets out this
shout
50 seconds until the incursion happens
40 seconds
then we're at 30 seconds and then we're
at 20 seconds then we're at 10 seconds
then we're at incursion and nothing
happens
incursion plus 10 seconds incursion plus
20 seconds
30 seconds 40 seconds 60 seconds
what in the world is going on here right
like the
like like that's the response of tony
stark the world should be like it should
be the end our universe should just be
blinked out of existence our earth
should be totally destroyed
and the entire universe blown up along
with it where is this in cursive earth
why hasn't everything ended it should be
the end of all things right
we should be done for and so with the
illuminati meet back up again right
this is probably the coolest moment of
the incursions arc right where like
everything's coming to an end the
illuminati meet back up again
and they're all kind of talking amongst
each other like what in the world's
going on like where
are our devices wrong right like did we
get a false positive were we told there
was an incursion and there was no
incursion at all
like what's going on here and the
responsive read is no our devices are
foolproof they work every single time
if if our devices said there was an
incursion that was supposed to happen
then it means it was supposed to happen
and if we got to incursion and there was
nothing going on
then something had to interfere
something had to have stopped this
incursion and that's when you have black
bolt of the inhumans who asked the
question
where's neymar the submariner from there
we switched to four
hours before we got to zero time with
the incursions right and what you end up
having
is neymar the submariner who's talking
to thanos
and proxima midnight and corvus glaive
and terrax the enlightened and black
swan and maximus the mad
what he's done is he created a cabal the
reason why that incursion didn't happen
is because the incursion was stopped and
the incursion was stopped when neymar
and his cabal
showed up on that earth obliterated all
the superheroes and then blew it to
pieces
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you